el país cuyo título he tenido el gran
privilegio de llevar durante gran parte
de mi vida y mi deber
my life
es oficial a los 40 William es el nuevo
príncipe de gales la tradición dice que
este título se le otorga al hijo mayor y
heredero del monarca del Reino Unido su
esposa Kate por lo tanto se convierte en
princesa de gales un título asociado
durante mucho tiempo a Lady di hasta su
muerte en 1997 posteriormente Camila la
segunda esposa de Charles nunca tomó el
título William el primer hijo de Charles
y Diana nació en 1982 tenía 14 años
cuando sus padres se divorciaron en 1996
y un año después su madre murió en un
accidente automovilístico en París fue
en 2003 siendo estudiante de la
universidad San Andrés en que William
conoció a Kate middleton hija de
empresarios ocho años después en 2011
dos millones de espectadores de todo el
mundo vieron su suntuosa boda luego la
pareja se mudó al palacio de Kensington
en Londres en los años que siguieron
William y Kate se han ganado los
corazones de los británicos en parte por
mostrar una imagen familiar modelo junto
a sus tres hijos George Charlotte y
Lewis
azulado nuestro nuevo príncipe y
princesa de gales estoy seguro
continuarán inspirando y liderando
nuestras conversaciones nacionales
una muestra de confianza a una pareja
que está destinada a reinar algún día en
el Reino Unido